no photo whoo hot Sui you may who knows
a BOSU is a character unlike any other
in Dragonball while the vast majority of
the series villains up until this point
were introduced as pure evil samosa was
the first character in Dragonball
history to actually develop into one
beginning his story as the Supreme Kai
in training with understandable naive
adolescent concerns by the ending we see
him as a radicalized megalomaniacal
genocide all psychopath characters like
cell and Frieza have fantastic utility
within storytelling because of their
pure evil nature and I actually wrote a
video on that too however because the
MAS who didn't start as a villain and
instead gradually developed into one
both he and Goku black showed us
something we never had seen before in
Dragon Ball and I'm going to show you
how they did that today I'm gonna dive
in depth discussing the character of
zoom assume analyzing the dialogue and
his unique character arc all in an
effort to figure out how and why writers
turn their characters evil
this is Samus
[Music]
okay so right off the bat I can already
hear what some of you out there might be
asking so what if samus who started as
someone with good motivations he
eventually became an evil character just
like Frieza and self why does it matter
if he started as good
well characters that undergo this
negative change have something which
characters like Frieza and cells don't
have emotional resonance and
believability they are rooted more in
reality and so we can understand and
empathize with their motivations much
more easily because we see how they came
to be that way now that doesn't mean
that we believe they're right or even
have a point but we can see more clearly
how they came to be which creates a more
realistic connection to the viewer a
well-crafted negative change arc
provides viewers with a character that
reveals interesting truths both about
the world and about the viewers
themselves when structured properly a
negative change arc can act as a
cautionary tale that can inspire great
change in all of us don't tell Harry but
to fully understand the negative change
arc and how to write one it's important
to first understand the most common arc
found in fiction you'll find this arc in
Marvel into the spider-verse
Dragon Ball Game of Thrones and pretty
much every other story taught and this
arc is called the positive change arc in
kmy Allen's book called creating
character arcs she describes the
positive change arc in it she says the
positive change arc is all about the lie
the character believes the character is
harboring some deeply held misconception
about either himself the world or both
in other words the lie the character
believes is sort of the characters flaw
often the main protagonists will spend
the majority of the story addressing and
coming to grips with this lie before
coming out on the other side a changed
person for the better having rejected
their lie and adopting a new truth for
example before the beginning of Dragon
Ball Z picollo jr. is revealed as the
spawn of the former King Piccolo as the
villain and antagonistic character for
Goku to overcome during the 2013 Chi Chi
Budokai and man is he a terrific
character during this portion of the
story unlike the conclusion to the prior
saga Goku elects to not show piccolo the
same faith his father meant as a result
piccolo recovers
then retreats what's interesting about
this is that piccolo jr. is not who his
father was but because he's the son of
king piccolo piccolo believes that
that's who he is this is the lie that he
believes and it takes forces from
another world and the son of his former
nemesis to show him that he is his own
person he's kind he's protective he's
selfless resulting in one of the most
emotionally resonant scenes in the
entire series and this brings us to the
negative change arc the negative change
arc is essentially the positive change
arc but flipped on its head instead of a
character that grows out of his fall set
into a better person the negative change
arc presents a character who ends a new
worst state than that in which he began
the story if we look at su masu
alongside someone like Frieza clear
differences are observed when we first
meet Frieza it's made abundantly clear
that this guy is insane in the most
dangerous of ways with goals that are
clearly insidious similar conclusions
could have been drawn about king piccolo
Vegeta
and self but this is clearly not what
our first impression of zou masu is he's
subservient patient motivated and
somewhat anxious with his pure heart and
good sensibilities reflected in the
quality of the tea he prepares for his
master the supreme kai of universe 10
kawasu however this anxiety he feels
leads him to say this ningún thwa
quantonium a motive it's insane anakata
this is one of the many pivotal turning
points for Zuma Sue's character which
perfectly highlights the lie that he has
been developing the belief that he is
better than mortals by virtue of the
fact that he holds a higher rank in the
cosmos this conflict of emotions morals
and duty is very interesting as author
george RR martin has said the eternal
struggle within a character's mind and
morals are where the true wonder of
complex character writing is found you
have to take your characters and you
have to put them through crises
that's what fiction and drama is all
about it's not your hero has a really
good time things have to happen that
close to characters who to question who
they are and what their place in the
world is and what the meaning of it all
is
to go through the dark nights of the
soul and times of fear and terror and
you know I've always taken as my mantra
they had William Faulkner's words in his
Nobel Prize acceptance speech where he
said the human heart in conflict with
itself is the only thing worth writing
about in reality people are complicated
they don't fit into perfect archetypes
very easily and it's this very same
emotional conflict that's observed in
zoo masu during episode 53 he goes on to
explain that he is concerned with
mortals never-ending cycle of
self-destruction thinking that their
continued efforts as history as shown
are futile what makes this more tragic
is that he's saying this from a place of
compassion wishing to spare mortals any
further suffering at their own hands
it's clear that he's deeply in need of
guidance to correct this naive viewpoint
however gosu gives him possibly the
worst piece of advice someone like him
needed at this time he says the jewsí of
the Kai's and the supreme Kai's is to
create not to execute punishment we only
watch over and nurture this does not
address the Masters concerns and only
reinforces his growing resentment for
the Kai's way of life after expressing
what he considers genuine concerns to
his master GU responds by saying it's
not our pay grade
it's in receiving this response that the
liza master had been curious about has
now become stronger what's more is that
it is immediately reinforced seconds
later by this despite learning his name
and consistently being engaged by Goku
the masu refuses to address him in any
other way than mortal check it out watch
the scene he never once calls him Goku
again emphasizing quite well through
dialogue how the masu views himself
above all mortals with that said however
it's Goku's first fight with him that
tells us everything we need to know
about his character having been
instructed by glow su against his wishes
to fight Goku the masu still considers
himself far above any mortal
demonstrated visually in his calm
counter of Goku's very first strike
notice his facial expression closing his
eyes dismissively as he pushes Goku's
fist to the side followed swiftly after
by him arrogantly announcing it ends
here claiming that the fight is already
over zu masu moving the
to deliver the final blow however
something happens this lie he believes
has led him down a path that caused him
to make a fatal mistake he
underestimated Goku Goku blocks the
attack the second Goku's hand meets a
masseuse is the moments a masseuse lie
is challenged his world his reality is
challenged this is also reinforced by
the musical score the second Goku's
counter meets masters attack
Goku blacks theme begins to play
signifying in that moment is a masu
became the villain of the arc instead of
seeing Goku's remarkable ability as an
indication that he might not fully
understand mortals he instead clings to
his lie and rejects the truth viewing
Goku and others like him as threats to
the God's divine nature and wisdom
inevitably spiraling towards their own
destruction
Zimmy su now believes a worse lie as a
result that not only is he above the
comprehension of mortals but he views
himself now as more enlightened than the
gods the concept an initial execution of
Zuma su is fantastic and as the villain
of this arc I thought he was perfectly
packaged alongside Goku black as the arc
progressed and in some cases stumbled
towards its conclusion samus's actions
became increasingly more severe and
extreme to a point where he became
unrecognizable however this arc as many
of you know left a lot to be desired in
its third act I don't think this is
necessarily a result of the Masters
character but more so to do with him
lacking similarities to the main
protagonist of this arc trumps
at the end trunks confronts fuse imasu
who has become mutilated and contorted
to a gruesome extent because of this lie
he refuses to let go of which is a
fantastic visual representation but I
think this altercation between these two
characters could have benefited greatly
by a popular concept found in films like
this in Sony's spider-man into the
spider-verse the main character Miles
Morales needs to start being who he
really is instead of who he thinks
people wanted to be but like many
teenagers he doesn't know who he is
and can't trust himself he's unable to
take a leap of faith because it's scary
taking leaps of faith is terrifying both
metaphorically and literally and this is
demonstrated brilliantly through Peter
be Parker's character acting as the
film's example of what happens and what
might happen to Myles if and when you
don't address the lie or fear that you
have Peter be Parker is a point of
contrast from Miles Morales showing what
happens when you let the lie itself take
over but thankfully over the course of
the film both Myles and eventually Peter
overcome their lies they believe and
come out on the other side more complete
people now I know what you're saying
those are two protagonists how could it
work with a villain and a hero well very
easily but first I want to point out
that there are a lot of things that work
about Zomato and Trunks is dynamic they
both care for the development and
prosperity of their respective spheres
of influence however Zuma soo does not
trust in mortal ability to handle
conflict trunks at the same time doesn't
believe in his own abilities to achieve
what he knows is good but what this
dynamical act was that trunks can't fall
down the same path Tomas who did so
what's the lesson don't be crazy like
Zuma soo I understand that trunks coming
to believe in himself and humanity is
the conclusion of his arc but it's in no
way linked his ammas whose experience
and I can't help but feel that that was
a missed opportunity a great example of
this can be seen in Sam Raimi's
spider-man series with the character of
Harry Osborn turning to the dark side
turning bad as he is consumed by his
desire to avenge his father's death a
wonderful example of a negative
character arc but also a wonderful
comparison to our Peter Parker who
suffered a similar loss and became
overcome by vengeance and this
exemplifies why negative character arcs
work well in showing us how easily a
character or hero could have gone down
the wrong path more easily than we might
have recognized
imagine if samaithu was a powerful
mortal character like trunks who like
him didn't believe in his or other
mortals abilities to prosper leading him
down a path of terror and arrogance just
like we saw with zu masu in the series
with this the arc could have been so
much more impactful at its conclusion
and could have actually had a satisfying
ending however with that said the future
Trump's arcs the mas who demonstrated a
wonder
design fantastic early characterization
and a compelling motivation making him
the first sympathetic villain Dragon
Ball has ever had and hopefully it won't
be the last
thanks for watching
[Music]